hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to agario now in this
episode my objective and ultimate goal
is to get to number one on the
leaderboard and I've never been able to
do it before never in my entire time
playing this game and have some hours
into it been able do it but I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna suck it up I'm gonna be a
man and I'm gonna do it I'm gonna also
be a woman if a woman could do it -
which I believe a woman can or anything
in between
I'm not offensive so without further ado
here we go and as you can see I got a
fresh new face for this fresh new start
good god why is it so goddamn crowded
over here I was just born I'm a baby
don't eat me Russia please don't eat me
nobody Kim jong-eun please I'm just a
babe I'm a baby I'm a baby yeah
god damn it I wasn't even your intended
target you dick the competition in this
particular endeavor seems to be vicious
sweet kids okay we're good good if I
only had a brain I could dance the way
the hours I could take a lot of showers
if I only had a brain doo doo doo doo
doo finally got a moment's peace but I
wonder when it's all gonna explode into
chaos preferably all over my face yeah
whoa oh good day for me
Boop ate me before right threw myself
into poop rather just it
that's not talking about how I threw
myself into poop gosh it's [ __ ] dude
I find a different server oh yeah baby I
didn't even know I was going for you you
just kind of went that way it's the way
it rolls baby when you got to face this
pretty all the ladies want to come out
of the woodwork for no reason at all not
to do with me hi marki Moo how's it
going you don't know you don't know what
you do you don't know you all don't
understand the ramifications of your
actions what the hell happened there
that's a bunch of [ __ ] when he
throws mass at me why didn't he throw
his meaty mass my way [ __ ] god damn it
Canada [ __ ] piece up ball oh you you
you spread a message of peace Oh help me
help me help me be the man that I need
to be oh my god shining balls
please don't shining balls [ __ ] [ __ ] man
da nose
[ __ ] man da knows they all fight over
there
I can stay nice and flexible up here oh
god it's def def that's the way to make
death oh I'm so bad at that I'm so bad
why am I so bad at that don't you know
me
there we go when you know when you get
it I made a joke I mean a joke
okey-dokey it'll get why why I hope you
die from I screwed you if I could just
stop being terrible at shooting my mass
at other people then maybe I'll have a
chance don't do it don't do it pewds
dudes no dudes no boots now I'm a bull
I'm a believin I'm blue I'm bleeding
you're no spiracle your goal Fraggles
Nergal don't do it you wouldn't do it ah
I see you wouldn't do it too much of a
chicken you're a coward
that's you don't have the eye of the
tiger box I'm the eye of the tiger oh
[ __ ]
Oh
dude watch it dude I said watch it dude
yeah I knew it he doesn't have the eye
of the tiger he's a big baby big whip
he's coward ya see ya ain't no coward
Frieza I saw a resurrection of F want to
be my friend I saw that movie what
happened to you pewds someone got this
oh my god
scary what the [ __ ] all right I'll take
it thank you thank you sir thank you I
guess
cool oh my god over here Jesus I want I
want something Oh God
okay might as well get out of there
because it looks like things are about
to get boxy oh boy
oh God lag why now oh god oh no oh no oh
no oh god no oh god that corner
that's so Corner hippie oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
that was a mistake
oh god damn it I hate life I hate life
everything about [ __ ] so happy oh yes
yes baby yes got you [ __ ]
yes yes yes [ __ ] seems like the sir just
got really empty for some reason if
you've added I've been really fortunate
with not meeting up with anyone that I
don't want to meet up with I had no idea
who's like this I thought it was gonna
be at least like not this something a
little bit not like this is we're only
playing against ourselves very uh very
lonely game we're playing here
yes yes yes come on give me some give me
some
Oh give me some and come on happy oh
[ __ ] come on just a little more
yargh oh [ __ ] you muggle
laughs like a duck I did stupid Oh God
I'm such an idiot [ __ ] that was not
worth the effort but at least something
happened yeah yeah that's right
what do you what you got now nothing
oops [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah I think
something went wrong with that server
because it didn't seem correct something
went horribly horribly wrong they're
like I could have kept playing and got
the number one eventually but man that
was just that was weird and like
immediately when I got off that server
it hot me do a different one that was so
bizarre
I have no idea what went happened what
went happened what would happen Kwame
suck homie takumu dacum oh [ __ ]
everyone's getting devoured I am NOT
going to be here goodness goddess
goodness Corbis greenness Corvo [ __ ] me
in the anus why why would you do this
why I'll go to this guy [ __ ] you Canis
Majoris [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and everything
you stand for I chose the other guy
because [ __ ] you god damn it man 302 you
thought you're free well I'm I'm I have
no soul I'm more than happy to sacrifice
anything for even the slightest of games
whoa hey whoa okay hi then well I guess
all right cool I'll take it to a cool oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] happened here okay well I'm
gonna use this
to escape or pop a bubble
Oh God Oh guys this is sealing better
not be the ceiling up there that's right
that better not be [ __ ] yeah that's
right oh you what the hell happened
there don't want to know don't want to
know boy there's a lot of goop there
this [ __ ] big dick ain't looking so big
this is so into the server's not servers
goddamn yes oh [ __ ] everything here is
wrong Oh everything here is scary so
scary it's so scary it's so scary
everything is so scary so scary you
don't wanna hang around me out I'm and
there we go oh I'm crazy but I'm stupid
I'm stupid crazy I'm cruising I'm Stacey
this approach thing I sent vast amounts
of death ha ha ha ha you suck dong [ __ ]
your [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you ha ha ha ok
well this is an odd situation to be in
oh I'm going to die [ __ ] no oh god what
the [ __ ] happened I have no idea that
was so weird
famous section famous sexy pictures of
vivisection 56 woo-woo-woo
[ __ ] criminy oh [ __ ]
ok I think yeah you you guys can't eat
me oh my god it's too stressful I can't
handle this this is all a bunch of
baloney is a bunch of baloney
Oh God what is with this server it's a
nightmare
it's a nuthouse it's a flip-flopping
nuthouse
oh god it's crazy oh it's all crazy it's
all great how did that happen
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Hoshi Hoshi Hoshi [ __ ] me huh why am I
holy [ __ ] balls oh yeah you can have
that but you can't have me dude you
can't have me I'm too big
too big too big too big I'm too big
don't even try yeah I don't even try
serious I don't know why you're still
trying you literally can't eat me
seriously I'm too big can t be hello ass
[ __ ] oh my god that's so stressful so
stressful I just need to carve out a
path I enjoy a little bit of success oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Leroy don't split
again [ __ ] me in the anus in the anus in
the anus anus janus janus janus
anus a noose [ __ ] man geez all these big
guys in the middle that's how it's
supposed to be so something was wrong in
the last one I know that now thank you
something was wrong in the last one I
have oh my god man is so stressful
I keep I keep cycling back to the place
I don't want to go because [ __ ] Mary oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay combined if I can
combine soon that'd be great I'd love to
combine now combining is like my number
one priority right now would love to
would love to would love to combine mine
yes please thank you okay perfect oh
[ __ ] god damn it almost had you oh all
right then they're going on theme but
why no don't do that don't do that don't
do that don't do that don't do that oh
man why aren't I reforming it why am I
not reforming yet why am I not reforming
yet like right about now funk soul
brother yeah that's right that's right
back off back the [ __ ] off oh okay this
was a mistake well now everyone's coming
after me did you watch me Fred the
needle cuz I'm a badass I'm such a
badass oh [ __ ] me no god damn it
yep [ __ ] ah son of a [ __ ] I can't
handle it
it's too stressful it's too stressful
it's too strong I can't no I can't do it
do it [ __ ] [ __ ] this servers a goddamn
nightmare
it's so scary oh I can't do it that guy
hadn't helped that reddit guy [ __ ]
stupid piece of boobs I'll let that
happen
whoop oh yes oh yes oh yes come here you
[ __ ]
yes come here come here come here come
here come hither whoa the [ __ ] happen
there
holy [ __ ] yes please walk into me whoo
okay that wasn't what I intended whoa
yes please yes please whoa whoa holy
[ __ ] things happen here [ __ ] balls yeah
they do
Oh God Jesus [ __ ] you [ __ ] you damn it I
had something going there I haven't even
made it on the goddamn leaderboard on
this [ __ ] thing [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] ha ha
ha ha that was really pointless you
exposed yourself now bait go after him
go after him
what are you doing bait go after him
yeah yep duping new bed pretty sure I
heard someone say that was up punk
thank you I'm not if I'm still not on
the board what is this place
what fresh hell is this whoa hey how's
it going there oh [ __ ] oh that beat guy
oh I'm on the board I think just by
listen the misfortune of another though
I'll take this thank you come here whoa
goddamnit huh no no no no no no god damn
it [ __ ] you I knew that was coming I
knew it I knew it was happening god damn
it whoa what are you doing out here
goddamn he almost walked into me [ __ ]
you well your [ __ ] thank you [ __ ] me
oh god they're all coming for me
I said death dozens it's approaching
that's just approaching
I'm in chaos all of Canis Majoris Oh
glory be to Canis Majoris [ __ ] you god
damn it I knew his coming us couldn't
get away fast enough [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright so that's enough acharya for now
this game is crazy that server was nuts
so anyway i have a ton of fun playing
this game i played it for an hour and 10
minutes now wow holy crap so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see more of this game I always
have fun playing this eventually I'll
get to number one but it just today was
not my day
so thanks again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video